la décision doit tomber dans une heure
patrick dils emprisonné depuis plus de
dix ans pour le meurtre de deux enfants
à montigny lès metz en moselle saura
alors si son procès révisé de nouveaux
éléments dans l' enquête avait amené le
procureur de la république a demandé à
la cour de cassation la révision du
procès procédure extrêmement rares en
france fanny vernis et raimu poissonnier
dans moins d'une heure
ils seront fixés depuis 12 ans monsieur
et madame deals attendent cette décision
12 ans qui clame l'innocence de leur
fils patrick condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour le meurtre
de deux enfants pour les parents
même si leur fils a avoué avant de se
rétracter
il n'est pas coupable la police leur
ferme ou une force 1 comme m'a vraiment
unique tout à l'heure tu es là tu es
parentois manger à voir si tu dis que
c'est toi et ça j'ai toujours pensé à ça
le 26 septembre 1986 alexandre et cyril
8 ans sont retrouvés morts lapider le
long d'une voie ferrée
sept mois plus tard un adolescent de 16
ans est arrêté patrick dils à vous puis
se rétracte en 1989 sa peine fait de lui
l'un des plus jeunes condamnés à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
mais un nouvel élément vient relancer la
faire un tueur en série francis heaulme
étaient sur les lieux le jour du crime
francis heaulme a déjà été condamné
trois fois par la justice et mis en
examen dans cette autre meurtre
même si ni les avoir tués il admet
curieusement avoir vu des enfants près
de la voie ferrée le jour du crime mais
pour l'avocat de la partie civile
la présence de francis heaulme le
disculpant rien patrick dils je crois
toujours à la culpabilité et de deal ce
patrick elle ressort à mon sens de ses
aveux ou si bien devant la police que
devant le juge d'instruction
elle ressort de la reconstitution telle
qu'elle a été faite
elle ressort du fait qu'à partir du
moment où il a il s'est rétracté sur ses
aveux il n'a jamais donné d'explication
il a toujours dit je n'ai rien à dire
cet après midi la commission de révision
va trancher le cas de patrick dils
si la présence de francis heaulme lui
apparaît comme un élément nouveau
important patrick 10 pourrait être
rejugée un jour et peut être même libéré
de la prison de toul dans les heures à
venir